راح نحط لكم حليب مع مسكين
شوكولا فستق لوز
وبيخلص اول واحد بنرجع بنحطه كويكه
فريز
اللي هو قمر الدين مش مش معمول
هذا الحامض
وهيدا ماء الورد اللي هو ابيض
لانه بلا تلوين
اول محل كان اسمه حلويات السلام بس اخذها
لسان العالم حنا متري حمام
بالوقت كان عم بيي عم بشتغل بالبيت
صار يشتغل بالبيت حلو ومحل نزل عند صاحب
الملك قال له لمين المحل قالوا لك يا حنان
قال له ايه قال له روح بلش بالشغل ونعزت
مصاري تعال عندي وبعدين بنحكي بالاجر
هلا
[موسيقى]
لا
أربع
ة
[موسيقى]
كنت انا والماما وفي شاب يساعدني بشتغل
معنا
اعجوبه يعني
انا وفي زبونين بني ادم بنات صبايا كانوا
قاعدين
بيني وبينه في انفجار
ربع ساعه
هذه البنايه
هذا الباب طار
ربك رحيم
انا كنت واقف هون
ما لحقت شفت الغبره جايه ما لحقت سكر
البراد هيدا تعبر قزاز كله بقلبه
واحد واقف وحنيكه كمان
سبحان الله
راح الدنيا كلها
[موسيقى]
يعني الاسعار بتطلع مثلا انا معروف من
البوظه الغاليه من زمان انه بالنسبه لغيري
انا طريقه شغل
كليا ما في عندي مواد حافظه ما عندي
بس مع الازمه الاقتصاديه والعالم ما فيها
وبتقدر تشتغل وهذا عم جرب قدر الامكان نضل
باقين كان عندي موترين
وقف واحد هلا من فتره
تاني بهالوقت هيدا اشتريت بالطريق يعني
اللي عم بيشتغلون عم بيروحوا كهرب
مش لحالي
[موسيقى]